so we're going to start off with a super
random equation question in fact if
you've got that spreadsheet there and
you've already put some stuff into it
why don't you just save it now and call
it
superannuation and that's where we're
going to begin
as you can see i have if you can see
really clearly
and then once you've got these three
columns set up year
payments deposited or you could just say
payment if you wanted and then interest
calculated or you could just say
interest if you wanted
let's have a look at the question and
then see what it's asking of us let's
have a look at the setup
a person invests ten thousand dollars
each
year um if you have your book with you
or if you're looking at someone else's
laptop maybe you want to draw that down
that's the first important piece of
information right
ten thousand dollars is this regular
installment that's going in
every year i can see that right at the
top
it's going into that superannuation fund
compound interest is paid at 10
per annum on the investment so that's
another key piece of information
10 interest per annum and i'm looking
at the rest there's no compounding
period that they tell us so we'll just
treat it as per year and then they say
uh the first payments made on first
january 2021
the last payment on first january 2040.
okay so that's all the information to
set up
if you're if you're jotting down you can
get those key numbers key dates
and if you're just you know keeping your
eye on the spreadsheet that's also
okay coming through zach now
uh whilst you're setting that up i do
want to point out and don't worry i'll
bring back the spreadsheet in a second
the question itself have a look it's
very long right and you've seen this
before these questions
are long questions they tend to attract
like six to seven marks minimum because
there's so much work involved okay
we're actually not going to go through
all the questions as presented what
we're going to do is try and just model
what the question is doing
with our spreadsheet and then once our
spreadsheet's set up we can use it i'll
show you how to answer any of these
questions
any way we'd like in whatever order okay
so what we're going to do is
we're going to now start to input what
are the years and payments deposited and
the interest calculated
you can squeeze through you'll be fine
thanks ray what year
does it all start have a look at the
question you guys can tell me
2021 so let's put that in 2021
that's our first year okay so i'm
putting that over here
on the left hand side
now before i go on to the rest of it
right i'm obviously going to have more
than one year in fact i also know
what's the final year so i could write
the next year is 2022 but
writing menus manuals numbers manually
that's for um that's for trump's i have
a spreadsheet that can do this for me
right
so watching carefully on the cell
beneath where you've written 2021 right
does anyone remember
how do i get it to start calculating
things there's a particular character i
need a particular symbol
i can calculate by using the side where
it shows you all the calculations right
yeah we can get to that but before i
access that i need to write
an equal sign that's what tells excel
what you're about to
type um please evaluate this okay so i'm
going to type in equals
now what i want to do is just go plus
one right the previous year plus one
okay so to get to the previous year you
can see once i hit equals
if you move your mouse around it'll
highlight what your cell is
and what its coordinates are right so i
want to go to that year above
and i'm just going to click on that cell
if you wanted you didn't have to use
your mouse you could have just
written typed in a2 and it would have
done exactly the same thing
okay um what did i do with that year i'm
going to
add one yeah plus one plus one
press enter did it work happy times okay
give me a thumbs up
if you're at the same point i'm seeing a
few what's happening right
okay you're just messing with me all
right now of course
the brilliance of excel and i'll just um
i'll highlight that again just so you
can see what the formula is if you
missed it right
it's a cell above i've added one oh and
by the way
i should have mentioned this right this
time if you at any point you lose me
okay you're like oh he did a step i'm
lost okay don't freak out just
keep on going with the person next to
you it's better that you keep up even if
there's only one computer between the
two of you
then you stop every time because
otherwise it'll take forever
the brilliance of this of course is that
i don't have to keep on
writing the same formula over and over
again highlight this
2022 cell and just copy it
right all it's saying is look at the
cell above and add one
so if i go down one cell and paste it
it'll just do the same thing
and i can do it for more than one cell i
can go down however far i need
i'm gonna guess it's around here
and i just paste and off i go okay
so you can see each one references the
cell above
and in fact i probably went one too far
yeah absolutely so you can see here's
the formula
right i've punched in the formula yep a2
plus one that'll give me the cell above
and then once i'm there i just copy that
cell and i paste it down below
has tavar got it tavare have you got it
i've got some random stuff on my laptop
all right there you go uh give me a
thumbs up if you're there
if it's looking good okay a few yes sean
max how are you guys going
yep parent tyler where are you up to
yeah okay good all right so
shh we've set up all the times so now we
start to think about well let's let's
bring the money in okay now the
payment that happens each year is how
much
it's ten thousand so let's go ahead and
punch in ten thousand make sure you put
the right number zeros
okay now when you hit hit enter it's
gonna just say ten 000. but i've
actually done
some um here's when i prepared earlier i
did some formatting i'm going to show
you how to do it as well
and um mine registers as a currency okay
now you can do this
too these two columns here b and c just
look closely
you can see i've highlighted columns b
and c
and then if you're on um if you're on
excel like i am up here in the home
tab you can see if you look closely
there's actually a whole button that
says
the dollar sign right so that indicates
whatever those cells
have list them as currency okay so if
you punch that in it says accounting
number format
it'll turn into dollar signs have you
got that there
yep fantastic
yes it should i mean there's comparable
features on same with apple and all the
rest
mostly okay feature parody please
okay eyes up for a second
all right so payment's gone in
what's the next thing that happens
so some interest gets added on right now
how do i calculate that
it's 10 percent but what am i going to
do with that 10 percent well
i'm going to type in equals because i
want something to be calculated here
i'm going to take whatever amount is
already in the bank account
which is just there on the left right
now to add 10 what's the easiest way to
do that 0.1
now i could multiply by 0.1
that would give me the interest but
actually i want to try and do this as
few steps as possible
i want to include the amount that's
already there and this interest as well
so instead of 0.1
or 0.1 i could just
add b2 that would be one way of doing it
your interest
plus the original or i could be even
lazier
i could just say whoopsie daisy i could
say i'll multiply by
1.1 that'll the one the 1.0
gives me the original amount and the 0.1
gives me the interest so now i hit enter
there's the interest added on already
does that make sense thumbs up okay good
okay now we're really close we're
actually
getting to the point where we can get a
pattern and then just keep it going
right so what happens the next year the
same two things happen
right what am i gonna do
there's a new payment made how much is
that payment
it's going to be the previous amount
right and then i add my
10 000 which happens every year so
there's my previous amount
plus oopsie daisy write the type the
correct character
there's my previous amount c2 because
the interest got calculated
right and then i'm adding my 10 000 for
my new payment are you following with me
yep i'm leaving the formula there just
so you can see it but
give me a thumbs up when you're ready
for me to hit enter yep okay fantastic
thank you
so there it is just as you predicted and
what's great is
the next interest calculation is just
like the previous one
right so i'm going to be super lazy i'm
going to copy
that previous way i calculated interest
multiplying by 1.1
and then i will paste it ishon question
that one now yes
right right well okay so let's think
about this right so i do
go from the end of 2021 i'm like oh i
have 11 000
in there and then i say i'll add 10 000
to that so that's why i'm at 21.
well you have a look right you you tell
me a new payment happens
right and then the new interest
calculation happens
yeah exactly okay are you following so
far
yes now actually all the hard work has
been done
right all the hard work has been done
because there's two formulas we just set
up
select both of them actually these two
uh b3 and c3
those two formulas are going to carry us
all the way through payment happens
interest happens payment happens
interest happens so let's
copy both of those cells copy both of
them together
maybe you've already done this and then
i'm going to scroll all the way down
and i'm going to paste all the way
through to the end of 2040 okay you
ready
paste i don't need 2041
how'd you do that okay so these are the
two cells
that have all my formulas in them right
so there's the payment
and there's the interest what i did was
i selected both cells
copied them and you can see the ants
crawling around right once you've copied
them
you paste it all the way down for all
the rows that you need yeah
so who got that final figure at the end
of 2040. have you got it there hands up
straight
i can see a few amazing thank you hands
down okay
so you can see if i scroll right to the
end there
this is the figure i expect after
whatever 20 years
yes okay fantastic
all right now let's pause for a second
um just lower your lids for a brief
moment
and um eyes up you don't have to put it
to sleep but i just want to make sure
i've got your attention
uh sean john it's okay if you're not
there yet surround you too
tavar just lower your lid for a second
i need to introduce an important
language to you here okay well done
you've created the model okay this is
exactly equivalent
to when we write out that long set of
working where we create the geometric
progression
and then we see like we get the formula
out but everything's happening
electronically right now it's important
that you recognize
have a look down here right the very
last cell
because i just copied what happened up
above and i just pasted pasted pasted
pasted
we usually get this final number in a
very very different way and i'll show
you how we normally get it
have a look back at the question okay
you can see
um if i zoom in here right
see this line in here this one here do
you recognize this is the kind of stuff
that usually comes from us
creating the formula for the sum of a
geometric progression
we've got to identify that we pull all
the numbers in and then
straight away you go straight to the
20th term right
but what we've done because for us it's
no it's no more difficult to get 20
terms as it is 200 terms i can just get
as many as i like right
you can see this formula here is not the
sum of a gpa
it's just this payment interest payment
interest and we've just done it lots of
times okay
now i need you to write down a really
important word for me it's in the
syllabus
and it's what we've just done here what
we've just created
in your in your books in your
spreadsheet is called recursion i'll
just type it for you
recursion you can type that in somewhere
if you like
or you could call this a recursive
method um the idea of recursion is like
a well you've done english right a
recurring motif what's a recurring motif
it's something that happens and you see
it over and over again and it reinforces
some symbolic meaning right
what we're doing here the recurring
thing is these two formulas over and
over again
they generate our answers for us okay